hello oh hi do you have trouble finding
a recipe to cook cooking for a picky
eater hi I'm Tucker Reynolds and I'm
going to let you in on a little secret
the tasty app is launching a new feature
called Botta Tui whoa how exciting
bottatui is a new AI powered chat
feature that uses very cool and advanced
technology here let me show you hi I'm
Tucker I'm a very picky eater but I love
pickles what should I make for lunch
we got
online Kirk you want something
natural hot pickles
oh Nashville hot fried pickles my
favorite
again this technology is very cool in
advance and definitely not the tasty
team responding to each of your messages
individually
check out badatui on the tasty app today
don't have the tasty app already what
are you doing